did you always know that you wanted to
be a parent like did you fantasize about
what like
your Traditions with your kids look
like I don't know if I fantasized about
that but I always knew I wanted to be a
young mom and I always wanted like kids
and I think that because I had so much
so early in life you know like a career
and so much responsibility that I did
feel even though I was scared I felt
like I was ready to be a mom and I was
ready for that like thing of my own you
know what was something you told
yourself or did you get to a point where
you're like it doesn't matter it's worth
whatever risk is is happening because
I'm I'm full I think you just get to a
point of like needing that change or you
just have to like trust your knowing
that everything is going to be okay how
do you trust your knowing I know I don't
know it's just something that you just
get to a point right and you just you
stuff it until you're so full and then
you're like you know what I'm ready I'm
okay with that like I I'm okay with by
the way you don't always get it right
the first time no I didn't get it right
recently like you you will continue to
not get it right throughout your life
yes and I think you just have to be like
okay that's and that's a little harder
when you have a public job there's been
so many times when I felt like a loser
or I didn't get the job or I've been
like sitting stagnant you know um but
you just like have to fill I found I had
to fill my life with things that were
real and
like that was enough at that moment you
know I had such a bizarre relationship
with rejection so early in my life that
I
appreciated what it gave to me which was
thinking there was enough room for
everyone and that being competitive was
unnecessary because there really is
enough room for everybody and still a
hard one
sometimes I it is and people have a
competitive Spirit like that's a healthy
thing I get that um but it is weird to
be a kid that like you find out like
it's not going to be you and you're like
okay I have to figure out how I function
through that oh yes yes but when people
ask you what what job did you not get
I'm like there's been so many I actually
can't remember I can't tell you like it
wasn't worth holding on to it so I
dumped it back there somewhere I won't
ever admit it because I don't want the
person who ended up doing it to like
your friend weird like I was mine still
it yes exactly I'm like I won't tell you
because but I'll admit like things I
auditioned for and then I guess they
might find out that way yeah but it's
it's I think the rejection thing is is
kind of coming full circle to me right
now cuz I don't think I quite processed
how much rejection you have to deal with
as a child actor um or just even in this
business in general because my son he's
doing um club sports and you have to
continue to like basically audition it's
not called audition in sports but that's
my
language totally I'm like are you ready
for rehearsal okay it's practice got it
um you got your costume on oh it's your
uniform yeah yeah yeah um he's so
annoyed um but he has to continue to
make the team right like every season
and he's always like what if I don't get
it what if I don't get it I'm like you
don't know how many auditions I didn't
get you don't know how many times I got
told no like we got to that's it you got
to just like Drop it if it doesn't work
out we move on I think I do have a
healthy relationship with rejection
because of our jobs like I'm like all
right or we're just beaten down yeah
you're over stuffed you're ready to quit
you're beaten down you feel liberated
turning pain into strike thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you